you know just this year alone
you may not know this but we've had 30
women be shot
seven of them be killed two of them were
pregnant and the babies got killed too
so
it's like it's this whole new phenomenon
with girls
getting shot
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bring to you the issues and
awareness that you need to know about
the gun violence on the south side of
chicago but also to raise as much money
as we possibly can to build a community
center on this much needed block called
o block it's called o block because it's
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs took
the o in his name and started calling it
oh block we decided we're going to keep
the o but we're going to call it
opportunity block i want to thank fox
network for giving me the opportunity
every single day to bring to you rooftop
revelations my thoughts my viewpoints
and opinions on matters in chicago and
around america
i'm really thankful today to have jemiah
johnson
who is from chicago
and she's going to give us a different
perspective on just life in chicago as a
girl
we've had some of the young men on the
show but we haven't really focused in on
the young girls
and so jamaica welcome welcome thank you
for having me you're welcome um i want
to say i want to jump right in and ask
these questions
first of all
how difficult is it
being a girl
in chicago because there's some people
who are watching who have no clue
on how difficult it might be for a girl
growing up in these tough areas
okay as some as some most of the time is
very difficult when you have family
members that's in games
um
and it's like
you just can't do certain stuff
um with them because
they
actually want to call it i've
uh see you and if they can't get them
they'll be out to hurt you so it's
certain things that you have to watch
out for
when uh you're in chicago
that you normally wouldn't have to watch
that's right in other cities yeah and
when you saw the ops because i want
because a lot of i know what you mean
but a lot of people may not know what
that is so when you say ops you're
talking about people who are in a rival
game right somebody else in a different
game yeah somebody has a different game
yeah so when you're out as a girl
you have to be
conscious of your surroundings um
because
if these rival gangs can't get
your brother or
or another person that you're connected
to they'll they'll
shoot even a girl
yeah you know i've been noticing this a
lot of girls
getting hurt you know and and shot
what's that about
i feel like um
if
if somebody close to you did something
to their family member or whatever the
case may be i feel like if they can't
get the person who did it they will come
out to get you basically so you think
that's a lot of what's happening in
chicago with the girls that's the reason
why so many girls are being shot because
i know just this year alone
you may not know this but we've had 30
women be shot seven of them be killed
two of them were pregnant and the babies
got killed too so
it's like it's this whole new phenomena
with girls getting shot i want to ask
you something else um
social media and stuff
uh do you feel like there's a lot of
tension and a lot of beefs getting
started with on social media with girls
and how that spills over to to the boys
yes i feel like most most females out
here in chicago want to be the gas so
they do the do what the guys do but not
knowing
how they can be after you they you not
knowing who after you who who they
observe they see you they might do
something to you so even yeah watch what
you do watch what you
are the girls are some of the girls in
gangs carrying guns and stuff too
uh
most of them but
wow yeah that's dangerous that yeah that
makes it very tough so
i'm proud of you because i know you were
in some tough environments um but you
made it through and you got through
school it was tough on you but you ended
up graduating where did you graduate
from i graduated from progressive
leadership academy at salutatoria
oh shoot
so you graduated from the school that's
inside our church miss curtsey is your
print was your principal
and
so you graduated successfully and
the thing that i want to get to is not
only did you graduate from the school
how was that school
so important for what you needed
compared to all the other schools it was
a small environment like i went to a
cps school and it was just like too many
people in the classroom i couldn't focus
because my all my friends were deaf and
i transferred to pla it was a small
environment and my cousin them all them
graduated from pla and they were telling
me how good the school was or whatever
so i just feel like it was a different
environment then once i got there this
the staff was wonderful all the staff
was wonderful
um
they helped me get a job they helped me
they helped me to be who i am today
right so the school
not only helped you get through school
they've stayed with you helped you get a
job and now
what are you doing to help the school
because i think that's real important i
am a mentor now
i mentor the students um so basically i
got hired
because
how good i was how excellent excellent i
was how they see me
progress
they hired me all right good so they
hire you and your focus is to do what to
to mentor the girls and help them work
through their own situations and
students yes and not just the girls the
the male 2 okay because some of the
males listen to me like i tell them like
not to do this you do that you i want i
want to see them graduate like i want to
see them become
better man i want them out the streets
like i don't want to see them on their
news
them in jail i don't want to see them
like that i want to see them graduate
succeed with life
yeah you know what i think that's what
makes you so special and i think that's
reason why you're gonna do great things
you're gonna achieve a lot because
people like me and you who have a heart
for like
wanting to make sure people don't go to
jail making sure people don't get shot i
think god has special work for us to do
so i want to commend you and thank you
uh for giving back because a lot of
people your age they go on and they get
whatever they get and then they they're
done but uh the fact that you're giving
back speaks a lot about your character i
just believe some great things in store
for you thank you all right so thank you
for being with us today thank you for
giving us a little bit about what's
going on in chicago with the girls and
what you're doing here at the school and
we're going to keep praying for great
success for you thank you all right
you're welcome thank you so listen um
it's been great uh today you heard from
a wonderful young lady um that i believe
god is gonna really bless her to do some
awesome stuff but like i say every
single day thank you for tuning in to
rooftop revelations and until tomorrow
peace
you